[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on 17th of August I'm
Cindy Yu The Spectators assistant editor
and your host for this week
coming up on the show
Trump is being indicted again you'll be
forgiven for losing track of the
lawsuits stacking up against the former
president but we have engineer on the
show today to break these down and the
implications for Trump's chances of
re-election
back in the UK today is results day for
hundreds of thousands of young people
this is the year that we are supposedly
back to pre-pandemic normalcy but is the
covert impact on young people really
over I speak to the education secretary
Jillian Keegan
we'll also be joined by spectator
contributors table young and Rachel
Johnson and I'll be asking them the same
question posed by The Spectators cover
article this week it's University still
worth it
also on the show I'll be speaking to
author William Cook about why some Brits
are falling out of love with Germany in
a face of a Hardline right-wing Party On
The Rise and an economy seeming to slow
down was Germany ever the modern
aspirational State some liberal Brits
seem to think it was
and finally from Germany to the world
the author and Kirk Anya vong bremson
joins me on the show to discuss her
upcoming book which is all about food
and the row it plays in one's national
identity she also busts them a favorite
myths about the origins of traditional
foods
and do subscribe to our YouTube channel
spectator TV is picking up thousands of
new subscribers every week and you
should be one of them just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon so you never
miss an episode
first up Trump's been indicted again
before this year no sitting or former
president had ever been indicted and
this isn't even Donald Trump's first
legal troubles but will any of it really
impact his chances of re-election I'm
joined by Andrew Neil
Andrew welcome back to spectacles TV
it's great to have you
good to be back
Andrew I had a moment of deja vu earlier
this week when I saw the headline Trump
indicted come back to Markov again so
for viewers who've lost track Like Me
who've lost track of the amount of legal
cases against Donald Trump he just
update us on what this latest one is
about
right he says quickly looking at his
notes
um well he is now indicted on 91
accounts I'll say that again
accounts he's been indicted and in four
broad indictments uh the original one
who's the first in chronological order
was to do with the hush money that he
paid uh a porn star uh or as a
registered opinion where he paid the
money they're calling it a house money I
must say now that's even small beer
compared to what has come since and then
we've had um special prosecutor Smith
bring two cards against him one is his
Mr Trump's handling of the classified
documents particularly of Mara Lago and
the efforts he made really not to hand
them back which is doing him more damage
than the act of taking them in the first
place then of course is the third
broader one about his behavior in the
run-up to January the 6th and post uh
what he regarded as the stolen election
and of course the riot broke kind of in
Capitol Hill that day and his role in
that and then of course this latest one
now these first three uh the Smith ones
are federal this one in Georgia this
week is State that's not it's not
federal but this is to do with the
specific efforts he took to try and get
those responsible for the count in
Georgia
uh to do as he wanted he lost Georgia by
fewer than 12 000 votes there's a famous
tape call when he speaks to the
Republican uh local official there local
politician uh the Secretary of State I
believe he was at the time you know for
for Georgia saying you just need to find
me 11
000 and several hundred bullets and I'll
be fine so that is all that plus fake
electors leading on people to change
their mind do different things this one
is interesting I always thought the
Georgia one might be the most important
of all
because
that tape alone was pretty hard to
explain he's clearly urging the local
official to find 12 000 votes somewhere
I just want to find
uh 11 780
[Music]
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state you should want
to have an accurate election
and you're a Republican
we believe but we do have an accurate
election no I know you don't no no you
don't you don't have it you don't have
not even close but also because this is
a state rap he's up against
if he loses he cannot pardon himself if
he becomes president again presidents
can't do that they can pardon themselves
at least we think they can for a federal
rap they can't pardon themselves for a
state rap uh what he's been accused of
which is under the Reichel laws which
are the racketeering laws which go back
to 1970 and this is a Georgia version of
the federal racketeering laws which
basically killed the Italian mafia in
the United States basically destroyed
the Italian mafia they're using that
against them as they've broadened it out
as well that carries a minimum of a
five-year sentence so there's no plea
bargaining there there's no uh probation
it's a minimum five-year sentence to do
that
and even the governor of Georgia cannot
pardon him so even a friendly Republican
couldn't pardon him so in many ways
that's the more dangerous one but you
add them all up the 91 indictments in
four separate cases which means that
how much time he'll spend on the
campaign Trail and how much time he'll
spend in the courtroom is a moot point I
mean there just aren't enough hours in
the day to do both yes to say so he'll
be going to trial for these cases next
year but in the longer term we might
have a president of America or former
president or president if he wins again
being in jail could that happen
yes it could happen I mean he could run
for president in jail it's happened
before he run the country from jail
well yeah it has happened before there
was a a American Socialist called Eugene
Debs
um he's what today we'd call a peace
Nick he was uh against the draft the
conscription in World War One
um President Wilson basically Adam
arrested uh during the water was the end
of the war and he was stuck in a federal
penitentiary
interestingly he was um but tried under
the then new Espionage Act which covers
more than Espionage and
[Music]
one of uh special prosecutors Smith's
cases against them is under that 19
under against Mr Trump is under that
1917 Espionage too so the same piece of
legislation affected Eugene Debs to put
him in the in the slammer and is now
being used against Mr Trump now that was
in the run-up to the 1920 election where
Woodrow Wilson couldn't run uh that
didn't run again he'd had a stroke his
wife had been running the country so the
Republican candidate was Warren Harding
Eugene Debs ran from jail from a federal
penitentiary and he got about a million
votes which was a little better than one
of the previous elections when he had
run so you could do it I think maybe a
little harder today because he didn't
win a Harding won by pretty much a
landslide but you could see some of it
being run I think the from jail the
though I don't think the trials are
gonna happen quick enough for that to
happen
uh you know the the special prosecutor
Smith has said he wants one of his cases
to begin on January the second which
would be two weeks before the Iowa
caucus which is the kickoff of the
Republican uh primary season uh good
luck with that the woman is reading the
case against uh Mr Trump in Georgia she
says she wants it within six months for
hers to begin
well she's taken two and a half years to
get here the 98 page document she's
produced doesn't really tell us anything
we didn't know about the behavior of Mr
Trump and his acolytes already uh and
she is indicted 18 other co-conspiracies
including Rudy Giuliani and uh that
somewhat mad woman Sydney Powell the one
that said the Kraken wakes I mean if
anybody is ever a sandwich short of a
picnic it's her
um and of course Mr Meadows who was his
chief of staff there is no way uh all of
that is going to be done in six months
time ready to go to trial so I suspect
more likely some of them I think we'll
probably get through the Iowa caucus and
then the New Hampshire primary which is
a couple of weeks later to the end of
January I think they will both happen
without any of the trials happening
Cindy I think there will be some
pre-trial hearings there'll be some
motions before the court you know
lawyers who see this is a dripping roast
they'll have this notes on the trough to
get as big a fees as they can from
everybody involved but I don't think any
trial is going to begin it may have
begun by super Tuesday which is in March
but probably not before then but Andrew
what does all of this mean for Trump's
campaign and its possibility of success
because on the one hand as you say
there's literally not enough hours and I
definitely know spending a lot of
campaign Finance on the lawyers as well
on the other hand it seems like if you
believe that this is a political Witch
Hunt against Trump You're simply going
to believe it even more with every
single uh method of lawfare uh some have
called it that comes up so what do you
think
well you're right a big chunk of the
campaign finance that Mr Trump has been
raising is going on legal fees and I
suspect that percentage will rise as we
get towards the trials and the law has
then spent me you really start to rack
up legal fees when you get into court or
in the lead up to court that's when the
real money is when these lawyers aren't
built by the arrow and well I mean I
think we're in the wrong business
uh I think we should quickly get a legal
education and start building by the hour
um so it's going to be hugely expensive
now what it's done so far is
Consolidated his base I mean he did joke
a couple of weeks ago I just need one
more indictment and I'll be unbeatable
in the Republican the race of the
Republican nomination well he's got his
indictment and he does look unbeatable I
must say he does look unbeatable for the
Republican nomination uh all these
indictments seem just to reinforce the
base that what he calls the Deep state
is out to get him and he says they're
coming from me now but if we don't win
this they're coming for you he says to
his base and they lap it up and it's
been a disaster for the other candidates
the um DeSantis campaign governor of
Florida thought to be the only real
Challenger to Mr Trump his campaign as a
Messner going nowhere he's fired some
people he's having to reboot it it also
Cindy puts them in a
the the people who would challenge Trump
it puts them in a really difficult
situation because it means people like
you and me are some questions such as
well was the election stolen uh is it
right that Mr Trump should face all
these indictments did he do anything
wrong does he deserve to be tried under
the racketeering laws for a criminal
conspiracy and they're terrified of
these questions because they're
terrified of saying anything that will
annoy the Trump base so as things stand
at the moment he is the Republican
candidate uh that's just the way it is
the unforeseen things can happen which
by definition we don't know but at the
moment he is the Republican candidate
now the conventional wisdom is yes yes
all this gets under the Republican
nomination again
but it is putting off Suburban voters it
is particularly putting off middle-class
Suburban women
who he got in 2016 and lost in 2020 and
none of this none of this is doing her
many favors come the general election
that's the conventional wisdom I think
there's a lot to it
I would simply put two markers on the
ground just to keep an eye on Cindy so
far and in a way I share that
conventional wisdom too the famous
soccer moms as they call them in America
um are not uh I'm not going to I'm not
going to like what Trump has been up to
with the fake election or January the
sixth or whatever
but there's no sign yet in the polls
that this is playing to Mr Biden's
Advantage because you would think all
right it's getting the Republican
nomination but Biden's lead in a
notional poll Trump versus of which
there is a lot of polling been done on
that now surely buying will be moving
further and further ahead there is no
sign of that in the poll Cindy all the
signs are is that they're nip and Tuck
they're around 44 they're both within
the margin of error uh there it is too
close to coal in these poles at the
moment so that's something to keep an
eye on and kind of in a way makes you
question the conventional wisdom second
thing I would look for is I'm still not
in any doubt you will lose a lot of
middle-class Suburban votes he he is
doing nothing he's consolidating his
base but he's doing nothing to win back
the people he that voted for him in 2016
but he lost in 2020 that's not happening
however there are signs that an
increasing number of working class
Hispanic voters
are moving his way up moving the
Republican way and therefore moving his
way too and although there aren't as
many of them around us there are white
Suburban middle class women
somebody's not getting back could be
made up for and remember if you take the
by these Hispanic voters who are
becoming more and more Republican over
the years you know that the house
recently elected his first ever
mexican-born Congressman actually a
woman and a republican from a district
that borders Texas with Mexico so that
is going on as we speak and that could
make a difference that that could help
counteract the fact that he's not
getting that moderate white Suburban
vote back again
fascinating Andrew thank you so much for
coming on to space HTV pleasure good to
see you again Cindy
now back home hundreds of thousands of
18 year olds are receiving their results
day today on a levels and other
qualifications three years from the
beginning of the pandemic their hopes
that are returned to 2019 grade levels
marks the beginning of recovery in young
people's lives but is it really so easy
I'm delighted to be joined by the
education secretary Jillian Keegan
Keegan thank you so much for joining us
on spectator TV thank you for having me
Cindy now compared to the turbulence of
the last few years on results day and
today's results seem to be back to 2019
levels is this a good thing I mean the
government must be breathing a sigh of
relief yes well that was the policy
intention that's what we decided we
wanted to do and we announced it two
years ago but of course there's lots and
lots of moving pieces that are involved
in making sure that that can happen so
yeah we're delighted that we're back to
2019 results and more importantly that
lots of young people have got their firm
or their insurance offer um so they'll
be off to their destination so 91 of
them which is fantastic news for them
yes absolutely and that percentage is
roughly the same as 2019 as well so that
is good to see but it was at some level
of massaging that needed to be done by
exam boards in the sense that you know
many of these students is probably the
first time they've ever done an exam
like this because of the disruption to
their school lives they haven't really
had the same practice us previous years
had so for them it is still pretty tough
year isn't it it's still an unlucky year
well I mean they've done brilliantly and
they've really shown uh the resilience
in a way and their hard work and it's
paid off but yes they haven't had uh
gcses but I've just been talking to a
bunch of students and they said that
it's actually the schools that have done
a lot of work and their head teachers to
prepare them even though they didn't
have exams to prepare them for these uh
really major exams everyone remembers if
they did a levels their a levels so
they're really rather you know sort of
crucial exams and they've done lots of
prep lots of mocks lots of you know
conditions so that they can really get
used to the environment even though they
did miss it at GCSE and actually a
couple of the students here were saying
that actually they were glad they did
that because if not they'd be going off
to University still thinking I've still
got my first exams to come and they'd be
a little bit more rare on their own
there so I think it's uh I think it's
actually been quite good for them to
actually you know make sure that they
get themselves ready because you can't
really go through your whole of your
student life without some kind of exam
yes a bit of a baptism by fire I guess
um do you worry about a socioeconomic
split there you know you talk about
um the preparation that some schools
have given to students it is clear that
some State schools are not able to give
that kind of resource to their students
and we've seen that in the absentee
numbers as well where many students just
haven't really come back to school and
private schools on the other hand do do
better do you worry about that
socioeconomic split but we always worry
about you know making sure the
disadvantaged pupils get the the most
opportunities I mean that's been
something we've been focused on since
2010 it's why we've introduced free
schools the multi-academy trusts it's
why we focused on school standards on
curriculum focused on giving
um you know getting that you know
equality gap down and we were doing a
brilliant job actually up until 2019
from 2010 to 2019 we closed that Gap by
9.1 but clearly the pandemic has knocked
us back a bit so we do have to now get
continue to focus on that and you're
right you mentioned absentees and that
is something that is particularly
concerning particularly those groups of
students who are now pretty much out of
the classroom or persistently absent
from the classroom so there's been a
huge focus on attendance and trying to
make sure that for September when kids
go back at school that we get those
children back in school because we know
if they start the first week of
September they're much more likely to
stay so there's been a lot of activity
over the summer with local authorities
and and with Academy trusts to make sure
that we do that but I think a lot of our
state schools a lot of our academies I
mean I'm actually at an academy right
now and they were the people telling me
about all that prep so I think most of
them have prepared their students well
for these exams knowing that they didn't
sit down and take gcses in the normal
way now Jillian the spectator's cover
article this week is asking the question
of whether or not University is worth it
and the author Ross Clark basically
takes a look at all the different ways
in which university life the these days
it's quite difficult really you've got
striking lecturers you've got student
accommodations really under under
pressure and very very expensive you've
got student loans by the end of it with
no guarantee of a good job at the end of
it and also things like Zoom teaching
not going away so the question is do
University students have too little
power to demand better service from the
universities that are meant to be
providing them the service for for quite
expensive fees and the last few years
obviously were exceptional circumstances
but even now it seems like some of these
covered impacts are still long-lasting
well as you say there have been
exceptional circumstances and that's the
great thing about really focusing on
getting back to normal which has been a
big part of what we've been trying to do
with a levels as well this year and I'm
sure universities will be taking exactly
the same approach as well everybody
wants to get
um back to normal but I think if I was
writing the cover I'd say make sure
University is worth it so make sure that
you think clearly about what you want to
do what you want to get out of diversity
which university you want to go to what
accommodations available in terms of
student power students actually have
probably more power than they ever have
over the years because we do have the
office for students they can make
complaints to their University but they
can also go to the to the office for
students to the adjudicator there if
they feel that they have been unfairly
treated and you know the consume they
are a consumer now in this process you
know they pay and invest 9 250 pounds
for their tuition and now clearly nobody
wants to see
um you know the the strikes that are
happening um in some universities where
some lecturers are withdrawing that
service that is outrageous and they
shouldn't be doing that and uh We've
written to them and urge them to uh to
resolve that dispute and they shouldn't
be doing that that's really their wrong
thing to do however I think I think
making sure there's many many options
that you have young people now have more
options than they've ever had so I was
very lucky I did a degree apprenticeship
years and years ago but not many people
have heard about degree apprenticeships
but now we have 140 different
occupations that you can access via a
degree Apprentice so if you
apprenticeships if you want to be a
lawyer an accountant a medical doctor a
space engineer a nurse a policeman
pretty much any
um sort of career you can think of you
can now access that via a high level
apprenticeship or a degree
apprenticeship so those are offers that
are there that were probably not there
in any great numbers for students a few
years ago so we're really focused on
making sure that there's a broad range
of offers and that's been part of the
conservative government's focus on
technical education as well building up
high technical qualifications
introducing T levels introducing new
Institutes of technology and we've
worked with 5000 businesses to basically
make sure that we have the right
technical education in place so that the
broader opportunities and not everybody
has to go just down One path yes but
that's quite an intractable problem
isn't it because it comes down to the
degree The Prestige of degrees you know
students and families
um think that that's what they need to
have how do you change people's minds
like that you've got your policies
you've got these opportunities but how
do you change people's minds when it's
about status symbol well that was some
people that was the um challenge I had
when that was the apprenticeships and
skills Minister and I used to think long
and hard how I could do that and I
thought the best way to do that was to
change the perception of degree
apprenticeships which is why I said we
need a medical doctor one we need a
lawyer one and we need an accountants
one because those three professions are
professions that everybody understands
and the reason you're going to
University to do these degrees is to
access those kind of professions so
we've worked with companies like Goldman
Sachs and Morgan Stanley and KPMG and
PWC all those aspirational careers that
people want for their young people and
we've made sure they are part of
Designing the apprenticeship system and
making sure that they have two offers
that are available people who want to go
to university and then go on a graduate
route and people who want to go before
straight out straight from a levels and
do a degree apprenticeship or a higher
level apprenticeship so they've been the
people who've really helped us and I
think now more and more people are
getting aware of that because really a
lot of people when they're looking at
University they look at it for lots of
different reasons but for sure one is to
access a great career like being a
medical doctor or you know being a
lawyer accountant a very aspirational
career so I've made sure that we've
fitted the aspirational careers into
that system so that everybody can
understand that this is just a different
route to the same destination Julian
Keegan thank you so much for joining
space HTV thank you Cindy
and following on from that the million
dollar question is University really
worth going to what with online teaching
remaining costly accommodation and
lecturers on strike today's students
seem to have a poorer deal than they've
had in years I'm joined by Toby Young
and Rachel Johnson
Toby and Rachel thank you so much for
joining me on Spectators TV our pleasure
now um you both have read our cover
article from the magazine this week
talking about all the ways in which
universities are just really I think
short-changing students these days would
you agree I mean Toby you can start well
um I think there it depends what subject
you do Cindy
um so um there was a survey done by
Bristol University which found that
um at Durham if you were doing physics
you got three times as as many teaching
hours as you did if you were doing
history
um and um I think that generally applies
across the university sector
um if you're not doing a natural science
or mathematics then you're going to get
less teaching time and less bang for
your buck but I don't think that applies
as much to Oxford and Cambridge so
because they have the tutorial system
and you get these kind of one-on-one
face-to-face tutorials every week even
if you're doing a Humanities or a social
science subject I think the discrepancy
is slightly less pronounced at Oxford
and Cambridge but in the rest of the
sector if you're doing something other
than a hard science or mathematics I
think you are being shortchanged and a
lot of this contact hours Rachel is now
virtual right because after the pandemic
a lot of lecture calls and professors
haven't gone back to in-person teaching
they've insisted on Virtual teaching I
know and I think that's absolutely
scandalous and I can understand why
Prime Ministers talks about rip-off
courses I mean it's this cohort is being
called I think the unluckiest cohort
ever and you know they didn't do gcses
they had their a-level grades assigned
in the last two years by
by their teachers but this is the first
year they're being marked so we're
seeing I mean the Prime Minister should
hail this a great reduction in grade
inflation but this is adding into the
problems of this particular cohort
um I think that online I think hybrid
teaching there is absolutely no excuse
for it I think up to a third of courses
are still being taught partly online why
why aren't the students students showing
a bit of the spirit of 68 why aren't
this to us not WETA
of a younger generation taking to the
streets and saying we don't want to you
know we want degrees not 40 Years of
debt which is what actually University
seems to be offering at the moment with
exorbitant interest rates you know I
look at my paycheck every month and I
look at how much it goes away onto
student loans I mean yeah about seven
percent now yes and there's some people
have no chance of paying it back
um and Toby you know what about the
power of students there you know Rachel
talks about students taking things into
their own hands but it does feel like
you know students are paying this money
to go to university their consumers of A
Sort but they don't have much power in
in demanding the kind of courses that
they want the kind of teach teaching
that they want
um is their power imbalance here I think
there is a power imbalance and I think
it's because
um there are too few universities I
think there are about 175 now in the UK
that's probably less than in the state
of Texas
um and that's one of the reasons
universities can still charge relatively
High tuition fees and neglect their
students when they get there because
there just isn't enough competition the
creation of the office for students
three years ago was supposed to make it
easier for new entrants to become
universities into the marketplace but it
hasn't really happened maybe it'll start
to happen but I think what we need to
see in order to give students a better
deal is much more competition and at
least some new universities saying okay
you're going to do most of your courses
online but it'll only take you two years
and it'll cost you half the price when
that starts to happen then the rest of
the sector May begin to get its act
together we have had a couple of new
entrants Cindy they haven't we've had
Buckingham and the University of the
what is it the humanities the one that
uh yes Anthony cell no is he AC Grayling
and uh started but presumably they have
more latitude to charge higher fees than
Oxford and Cambridge and of course as
Toby was pointing out you know Oxford
and Cambridge are still hugely good
value because you know half their intake
comes from private schools where parents
have been paying what 50 Grand We Now
read a per annum to educate their
children there so at 9 000 pounds a year
at Oxbridge that is a snip you know that
is chump change to these parents who are
if they are stumping for their students
isn't it compared and also you get much
better much bigger bang for your buck at
Oxbridge because of the tutorial system
and also you do get housed I mean that's
the other issue for this year I read
some something like a third of students
aren't even being offered accommodation
in the university and if not the
university not even in the town I mean
Bristol is busing kids to a somewhere a
campus an hour away and housing them in
a kind of Bibby Stockholm situation I
mean what what is happening is if
nobody's right it's about you know
there's too much Supply not enough sorry
too much demand and not enough Supply
well if that's the case why aren't
people piling into the university sector
why aren't Toby and I starting the
university you know our own University
tops that's an idea yeah I did think
about that Rachel
um one of the reasons I um applied to
become a non-executive director of the
office for students back in 2018 uh when
your brother Joe effectively set it up
was I wanted to gain some coal-face
experience so I could then set up a
university set up and yeah
um unfortunately I only held the job for
about eight days because I got canceled
um but um yeah I mean I'm I'm up for
that I've you know I've helped set up
four schools um my father started the
open University which is still I think
the largest university in Europe if you
judge it by the number of students so if
he can do it why can't we
you know everyone wants to go to
Oxbridge we should locate it in Uxbridge
and which is not the University of
Oxbridge
an Oxbridge degree you know you know I
just think it's a bit of a typo yeah and
be there to be the chancellor
I think there may well already be a
university of Uxbridge um uh what what
one point I wanted to make is about
housing um Cindy is that one of the most
scandalous things about the
extraordinary uh restrictions imposed on
University students during the pandemic
is that even though
um all they're learning for more than a
year was remote and they weren't allowed
to leave their Halls of residence so you
know for most of them they'd be far
better off going home uh rather than
being cooped up in these dorms and kind
of stuck on their computers all day but
the universities locked them into these
housing contracts said sorry you can go
home if you want but you're still going
to have to pay full rent for 12 months
that was absolutely scandalous and to
Rachel's point about you know where are
the rebels there is a class action suit
percolating Away by students against
universities for having ruined three
years of their lives during the pandemic
um and it looks like that'll come to a
head next year but it's not all bad news
from the Free Speech Union's point of
view the organizer station I set up
three years ago one of our largest
donors was the largest donor to Durham
but he was so disenchanted by Durham's
Draconian covid restrictions making life
miserable for students at Durham that
he's now giving the money he would
otherwise give to Durham to the Free
Speech Union
wow so there's the beginning of the
University already but Toby and Rich I
am surprised to hear you both say that
the problem is not enough universities
haven't we been talking about in the
last few years degree inflation you know
the government talks about these Mickey
Mouse degrees isn't the problem that
students who might be better off doing
apprenticeships or just getting a job
are being shoved into university courses
that don't really teach them anything
and they still have to saddled with the
same amount of debt as an Oxbridge
student Rachel
well I I mean I think that students
should be encouraged to do non-academic
disciplines as much as they can I mean
looking back on it I mean I don't know
why I read greats at Oxford I mean it
was completely unsuitable degree I was
probably completely unsuitable for it um
you know there were huge upsides it was
just at a time where everybody presumed
you would go to you know top university
a Russell group one and read something
you know disciplined you know that that
qualified as a proper University subject
but now we've seen the evidence and Ross
Clark's piece really sets this out
that their graduate degrees do not
translate into graduate jobs and a lot
of graduates are like working bars doing
low paid low-skilled jobs which are for
which they're vastly overqualified now I
don't know what the answer to that is
and it just strikes me that there should
be some sort of transfer system whereby
you know the young people who are able
and fit
should
um maybe not go to university as soon as
they do I've got a young nephew who's
going who's just 18 and if I feel I was
immature when I went I mean I think a
lot of people do feel they're not ready
to go and yet we've got two and a half
million of economically inactive people
who are being paid to do nothing rather
than these young economic you know these
young also economically inactive people
who are paying to learn skills it seems
to me that there's a problem there and
if you if you're a really creative
Chancellor you would maybe pay that
economically inactive 50 year olds who
are sitting on their asses since the
pandemic to re-skill in some way to use
these you know take up one of these 29
000 courses meanwhile you should
actually enable the really young kids
who maybe are going to University you
know far from that even where the
university is based not really ready
because of the three-year pandemic pay
them to do something else for a bit and
then when they've learned a bit more
about themselves in the world and what
they want to do with their lives then
they go to university I just think
everything's the wrong way round at the
moment but that's a that's a really
separate issue
it's a really interesting idea um Toby
and Rachel I'm afraid that's all we've
got time for but thank you so much for
coming on to spectator TV thank you
thank you Cindy bye Toby hi Rachel
next are some breads falling out of love
with Germany with a rising Hardline
right-wing party and a slower economy it
seems like Germany has just as many
challenges as any other country in this
week's magazine William Cook asks
whether some Brits haven't been
oversimplifying the country he joins me
now
so William Cook thank you so much for
coming on to spectator TV and you write
in your piece that liberal Britain has
fallen out of love with Germany rather
rapidly recently and first of all can we
talk about what's happened in Germany to
make people reconsider their rather Rosy
abuse of the country certainly well I
mean you know three things have happened
really
um one is that Marcos left and this kind
of Talisman of of uh the kind of Liberal
Liberal left in Britain kind of exited
the stage so it may be there Mitty yeah
they're they're quite isn't quite this
kind of totem pole for for kind of
progressive uh Britain's uh to look at
and get slightly dewey-eyed about
anymore
um the afd alternative for Deutschland
has been on the Rise
um to what extent that is a hard left
party or a far right part a hard right
party or a far-right party is a matter
of debate but it certainly caused quite
a lot of this quiet in Germany and also
in in Britain certainly among people on
the kind of uh Progressive uh side of
politics here uh and also the third
thing I think is the um the German
economies had a slow down
um
it's Jeremy's been in recession will be
from a pretty
um Big Head Start
um my view is that this is a cycle and
it's going to come out of it but
nevertheless I mean I think I think it's
kind of re-evaluation really I don't
think things are quite as bad in Germany
as the papers like to make out but
equally I also don't think they were
quite as good as they were before so I
think you know it's a kind of wake-up
call for for for people in Britain uh
you know things things were not it's a
big complex country with
80 something million people living there
and a lot of Industry a lot of big
cities a lot of small towns and it's got
a lot of the same problems that Britain
has and I think you know Britain's are
kind of coming around to that idea yeah
because there was a moment maybe
especially durian before brexit where
you know people were thinking you know
articles and books written to the name
of what does Germany get right all of
these kind of things like what can we
learn from Germany the real leader of
Europe and all that sort of stuff yeah
why Germans do it better I mean you know
that was a sort of convenient Hook and
the books actually John Compton looks
actually kind of more more kind of
nuanced than that but um even so I mean
it was it was it was a nice idea wasn't
it I mean it was partly because we were
all stuck in lockdown and kind of
watching the tally and obsessing about
the news and of course Trump was was you
know going wild on Twitter and there was
this kind of Log Jam in the uh British
system in in the post-brexit um era
particularly with Theresa May and then
after the Theresa May Log Jam you had
the Boris Johnson roller coaster and
people who at the time who didn't want
either to be in this gridlock with
Theresa May or in this kind of rather
chaotic and unpredictable setting with
with Johnson and then looking across the
pond and seeing Trump going on Twitter
and saying all sorts of stuff Merkel
looked like the only grown-up in the
room at times and um you know some of
that Sheen has come off another big
thing that's changed of course with
regard to Merkel is that one of the few
things that Trump got right possibly a
stock clock tells the right time twice a
day is that you know he he he he did
sound off about Germany's dependence on
fossil fuels Russian fossil fuels in
particular and Germany's actually done a
u-turn on that pretty quick and it's
it's quite remarkable how how quickly
they've changed tack but you've got to
say he was he was kind of right and um
you know it was a it was some
unnecessary kind of change I think the
invasion of Ukraine did mean that
Germany set to rethink and you know it
didn't kind of doesn't look like it's
kind of way out in front the way it did
to people before yeah a bit of a knife
point of view I think but I mean it was
understandable like I say if you're
stuck in lockdown glued to the tally and
all you've got to watch is 24-hour news
and you see Merkel shuffling around
looking
um you know business-like and you see
Trump and Johnson and and mail all kind
of doing their different things it's uh
it's a natural conclusion to come to but
I think some of the Sheen has come off
the Merkel Legacy uh certainly and I
think it's always been more of a
reflection of domestic politics here
where we think of foreign countries
right I mean it's almost less about
Germany itself our view of Germany and
more about what that projects what we
reflected on domestic politics here
because it was more oh look how bad
brexit is or look how bad Trump is look
how stable they are with no actual
interesting understanding Germany to the
degree for example that you do and
you're writing your piece for example
with the difference between Berlin and
Countryside the difference between
different demographics in Germany all of
these things not actually what people
are interested in well I'm still just
interested in Germany as a foil for the
UK yeah and I think that as you said
that applies to a lot of countries
America as well for instance you know
it's it's tempting to kind of look for
what we want to find in these countries
and certainly if you go to Germany yes
you can go to Berlin or cologne or
Hamburg and meet a certain kind of
demographic and come back with a
completely different uh point of view
than if you go to small towns or
Villages or the countryside or or
Farmland in Bavaria or whatever it's a
very very uh diverse place and uh rather
like America I think I think America is
a helpful analogy I mean it's a it's a
federal system rather like America local
politics Regional politics is possibly
more important to a lot of Germans than
National politics you know their their
state capital is their Capital Northern
Berlin you know they're they're they're
kind of you wouldn't say looking inwards
but they're they're they're often rooted
in their in their own communities and
it's it's not like all Germans are
berliners by any means yes absolutely
and it's interesting that as Merkel
Legacy is being reevaluated now in the
years since she has left office in
Russia you mentioned is one way in which
it's being reevaluated I also think you
know I write about China look at China
when you look at Germany's China policy
that I think also has a some some level
of reevaluation that will come in the
future you look at the comprehensive
agreement on investment which is the
Chinese EU Financial deal pushed through
by Merkel very much but at the moment
it's dead in the water because the
parliament will not ratify it and that's
again another miracle Legacy you know
you say that the war Ukraine has made
Germans re-evaluate Russia a Chinese
re-evaluation I think hasn't quite come
yet and I think it's it's fascinating to
me how merkel's Legacy could be changing
even after she leaves office absolutely
and I think we only saw one side of the
coin I mean to be fair going and
covering 2017 election for instance and
going back in 2021
for The Spectator and other people too I
mean I never felt that the Germans were
quite as rosy-eyed as certain people as
Starry Eyed does certain people here in
um Britain were we tended to see the
kind of foreign policy she she presented
she was the right person at the right
time in terms of foreign policy as it
seemed then I mean obviously not now in
the light of Ukraine but um at the time
we tended to just see the foreign
possibly rather than the domestic pitch
it was a lot more mixed I think the
other thing to remember about Germany is
I mean the the system's very different
there in that not just in the business
tag and the German national Parliament
but all the way down it's a whole
network of coalitions
um and uh you know it's the the the
Constitution which you know partly is a
legacy of of of Britain's role in in
recreating Germany after the second
World War uh the bundles Republic
completely new country essentially
um is that it's almost impossible for
one for one party to to sort of drive
through everything they want to do all
four leader to I mean we tended to see
Germany equals Marco but actually on the
ground it was much more of a sort of
collective process and usually a case of
not just an abundance tag but also in
the regional parliaments as well
different parties working together and
of course the wild card now is the Riser
fan alternative for Deutschland FD and
the fact that this is a party uniquely
almost in in German politics modern
German politics that the other parties
won't work with and that is the big
question now because they're polling
something around 20 at the moment and
normally when a party gets to that level
that you'll find on reachable level even
in National level you know they're
working with other parties and and you
know there are some quite unusual
alliances in German politics for
instance the CDU which is roughly
speaking the conservative party in in
Germany is is is working on well in
national government with the green party
and also you know historically a lot of
times they've they've they've done it
not not just on a national level but on
a regional level as well and yeah afd is
the one party that the other parties
weren't work won't work with and um
Friedrich merch the um uh CTU leader
markle's successor in uh that regard he
then had to roll back quite recently
because he was saying we're never going
to work with these people on a national
level but you know we have to maybe
think about it if there's a reason well
he just kind of floated the question
floated the idea really that of possible
the possibility of working on on a local
level and then had to roll back on it
very very clearly I mean he never said
he would but he just kind of raised the
idea and then the reaction was quite
strong but if you are going to have a
party which is polling 20 in a sort of
you know system of fortunate
representation and uh Coalition
governments on Regional and National
levels then it's quite a big step to say
that if this part is on 20 we're not
going to have anything to do with them
but that that is the situation at the
moment and that that is the big debate
in Germany at the moment is is you know
to you know should we ban these people
should we should be you know think again
whatever I mean I mean and obviously it
throws up a lot of um difficult
historical questions as well but your
point uh to people who are concerned
about the afd people who are concerned
about the economic slowdown is that
Germany has never been that perfect but
at the same time it can also overcome
these current issues which frankly all
modern democracies face yeah I think so
I mean I think what's happening is that
the CDU I mean this is another thing the
the Christians I make Union the CDU
Miracles party was always a kind of heat
fight conservative party more than that
right party but it was a conservative
party nonetheless and she really took it
bit by bit very gradually uh for over 16
years now office but she took it to the
center ground away from the center right
to the center almost made it a kind of
soft left party in some respects now
this was politically very astute in
terms of domestic politics in that this
really emasculated the SPD which is the
kind of Social Democratic soft left
party in Germany and kind of you know
stole a lot of their territory and left
them with nowhere to go but it did open
up the space on the right and this space
has been filled by afd I think what's
going to happen is the CDU is and I
think it's already starting to happen is
going to be moving back towards becoming
a center-right party again and this will
prevent there being a really big
Breakthrough by by afd I think it will
be more manageable but it's it's still
significant it's still troubling and
it's still a cause for concern certainly
William thank you so much for coming on
thank you
and finally how important is food to
your sense of national identity I know
that as a Chinese person it's very much
Central to mine according to a new book
by the chef Anya Von brimson that's the
case across many different cultures and
yet it's not always clear that these
national dishes really are so integral
to a national identity she joins me now
Von bronzen thank you so much for
joining spectator TV
thanks for having me so Anna what made
you want to look into this question of
food and national identity to start with
well it all started long time ago when I
published my first cookbook called
please to the table in the 1990 and it's
about the food of the former USSR and as
the book went to print
um the USSR collapsed and separated into
all these different countries and by the
way I was born in Moscow so I was home
territory so I kind of saw witnessed
this nation building as it was happening
in real time coming back to this
post-service faces and seeing new
identities new Cuisines new
articulations what it is to be a nation
and of course these days uh we have this
paradoxical situation where on the one
hand Nations and nationalism seem almost
obsolete in this day of uh in age of
absolute globalization and at the same
time they've never been stronger uh we
have this compulsion to tie food to
place to search out for the roots of
what we eat so what better prism to
examine this Paradox than food and I
decided it would be rather than just
kind of talk generally it would be nice
to look at natural dishes of certain
countries foods that we love uh that we
know that have become extremely
globalized like Ramen Pizza tortillas in
Mexico this kind of things and see how
we can trace the Rise of Nations and
nationalism through these dishes I mean
it sounds fascinating I haven't read
your book just yet but I definitely want
to what made you choose the different
countries you went to six different
countries what made you choose them is
it just how International the food was
I think partly it was the dishes
themselves you know so I started in
Paris where the whole idea of a nation
and National Cuisine was forged You
could argue with the French Revolution
and with the French chefs in the 19th
century articulating this idea that you
know food is a uniquely French cultural
product and Export so I look at Potter
which is considered France's national
dish and it's a stew a soup vegetables
all in one cauldron that was really some
call out and sacred in in Paris so I'm
looking at what happened to that dish
and I'm finding that the French church
is not interested anymore in the idea of
the cuisine which is so funny and then I
look at pizza and pasta al Pomodoro in
Naples which is so iconic and so
important but think about it Italy
didn't exist until the 1860s there was
no such thing and Pizza and Pasta
Pomodoro are uniquely Neapolitan
entitled to the South uh tomato is where
uh Naples is where the Tomato first made
this appearance so it goes like this
then I go to Japan which is fascinating
to everyone and has its own fascinating
nation-building product process around
the same time as Italy 1860s 1870s Japan
is a collection of disparate islands
with like no national identity no
National Cuisine then comes the major
restoration the kind of push to pull it
you know to pull it together into one
country and again what happens to the
cuisine and I'm looking at Ramen which
is a fairly recent addition
to the Canon and it's Chinese in fact so
here we have one of those paradoxes and
I'm also looking at Gohan which is white
rice which is a hollowed Cornerstone of
washuco which is a national Cuisine of
Japan but is it real that National
Cuisine so again I'm looking from there
I moved to
um Spain to look at Tapas which is not
so much one dish but a meal a tradition
that also just took off tremendously all
over the world because we all are crazy
for small plates and I'm in civil in
Andalusia in the rothea uh looking at
how that region that sultry South
represents all the cliches about Spain
the Flamenco bullfighting and how that
came to be and how food is part of it
from there I go to Mexico to Oaxaca
which is the most indigenous state in
Mexico and I'm looking at the corn
tortilla and mole which is a complicated
elaborate stew that represents the
fusiony aspect of Mexican identity the
fusion of European and Indigenous
influences and I'm looking at how that
identity is playing out and then from
there I go to Istanbul where I have a
home so it's a natural for me and I'm
looking at another small place tradition
which is meze
which is you know very popular now and
I'm looking at ottoman multiculturalism
through that food tradition
so these are places I know well that
I've written about before that made
sense for me but there are also sources
of some of the most fascinating Cuisines
and traditions that we know of course
the book could have been endless it
could have been 20 dishes people say why
didn't you do uh chicken zika masala as
a British national I'm saying well you
know it's been written about the other
good good good good
books about it so I um I went to places
that I had a connection to that I've
written about previously but looking at
a completely uh from a completely
different angle yes no absolutely I
think you can write this book about
almost all countries in the world
probably all national identities
um this question about you saying are
these real you know that's a really
interesting word I think that you used
here because I think what people often
forget is how recent how New Nationalism
itself as a force the national identity
itself is and so often these dishes
themselves don't have the kind of
provenance you know we often think that
you know I'm Chinese we talk about our
thousands of years of history but I was
actually shocked to find that the chili
you know this idea of Chinese food being
spicy the chili was only introduced to
China in the 1500s and from South
America so what makes something an
inherent part of a national identity is
it always kind of constructed by the
people who identify as that I mean how
real is anything is I guess what I'm
asking
no absolutely you're right I mean there
was no identification as a national uh
the category almost didn't exist
um until more or less the French
Revolution or the late Enlightenment uh
and the articulation of the idea of
nation As We Know It uh with a common
language and common customs and the idea
of a national Cuisine comes even later
so everything is constructed and looking
at so many myths uh I was shocked to
discover how how many lies there are for
instance the whole uh you know pizza
margarita which is named after this
famous Italian Queen who supposedly
tasted it post unification in Naples
even though she was from the north and
allowed it to be named after her and
it's repeated in all the scholarly books
but it's a total lie
you know concocted by certain pizzeria
in Naples in the 1930s you know Ramen
again is a Chinese dish and the inventor
of the instant Ramen Momofuku Ando is in
fact from Taiwan and he in fact didn't
even invent it there was another guy
also from Taiwan who he bought the
patent from so once you look everything
is full of holes all these myths and
um it's really fascinating how it is but
in fact what I argue what is authentic
authentic it is is what feels authentic
to a particular group at the moment
um so on the one hand I'm very critical
of nationalism we're seeing so many ugly
manifestations of it uh on the other
hand I sort of have a grudging respect
for the narrative because the narrative
is extremely powerful and food is
generally a powerful medium to convey
anything so once we impose those
nationalist narratives and tropes or the
food it becomes almost explosive and my
last chapter which I really wish I
didn't have to write
is on Bosch
they
beat soup that Russians and ukrainians
claim as their own and I was born in
Moscow eating borscht almost every day
my mom is from Odessa Ukraine but she
lived all her life in Moscow then we
immigrated so I had a different epilogue
in mind for the book but then the war
breaks out and with it that whole
ugly argument about borscht because
Russians are suddenly go to Ukraine and
say well it's our dish and ukrainians
say you know how is it possible because
in fact it's a Ukrainian dish so my last
chapter is a very personal and very
tragic meditation on this difficult
aspect of national identity and food you
know we have Ukraine being attacked by
Russia
I felt like I had to renounce my past
and my russianness because I just I
wanted nothing to do
but with that country I've been living
in a state since I was 11
but that wish has signified home for me
um I kind of had to just abandon it and
said you know look it is Ukrainian and
if I'm going to cook it and think about
it I'm gonna do it from a Ukrainian
perspective I'm going to learn Ukrainian
read about it in Ukrainian talk about it
to ukrainians
um and that's it goes to show you how
immediate a powerful food can be yes
well Anya especially for diaspora like
you and I who moved to a different
country in childhood that food is a real
immediate connection so I can't imagine
the kind of conflict that you've been
going through in the last year
um with your identity it's been very
wrenching yeah but at the same time
Bosch
for solidarity
so I've been doing this incredible uh
job of promoting it and raising
awareness of their situation through
food again because food is so immediate
um so this is what the book is about so
many issues they're complicated they're
fascinating and I'm using food to look
at history politics social constructs
um and just the idea of home and what it
means to the people yes absolutely well
Anya thank you so much for joining us
back to this TV and I hope viewers at
home do pick up a copy of the book I
know I certainly will be
that's it for this week once again if
you enjoy spectator TV do subscribe to
our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon so you never
miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
next week
[Music]
thank you
foreign